I will not be taking any questions
though I know you will ask them I do
have a brief statement I want to make on
behalf of Mr Mills we want to start out
by saying that understandably the the
nation is the nation's heart is filled
with frustration with grief due to the
death of Tyree Nichols and we understand
that
these emotions absolutely should be
channeled into demanding change in the
way that we police our communities
it's also vital that we extend these
demands to the way that we treat
minorities and people of lower incomes
in our criminal justice system
it's not forget that my client is a
black man in a courtroom in America
this is a country where black people are
incarcerated at five times the rate of
white people a country where black
people are 7.5 times more likely to be
wrongfully convicted of murder than
white people
much has been said about the ways the
system has failed Mr Nichols
I will work tirelessly to make sure that
the system does not fail Mr Mills and
that a fair outcome is achieved
I want to remind everyone that the
resolution of this indictment
to which Mr Mills has pled not guilty
must be carried out without sympathy or
prejudice
that it must be based on the facts in
the law and not the raw emotions that
our country is currently experiencing
Justice for Mr Nichols will not be
achieved at the expense of justice for
Mr Mills
we have a very long road of
investigation and litigation ahead of us
again I implore the public to be patient
to be cautious in judging Mr Mills we
look forward to defending him so why is
he not guilty why is he not guilty
he was on a group of five officers who
brutally beat Tyree Nichols why is your
client Desmond Mills Junior not guilty
why they didn't come to court like the
regular when you watch that video why
where's the proof in that video that
your client isn't guilty
he's guilty of being in a group of five
who
behave like a like a pack whose Behavior
was inhumane according to their police
chief